the opening scene features a maintenance
worker named Chad who is renovating a
room of a grand old building during this
a hole in the wall behind him spits up a
ball of putty Chad attempts to cover it
but his efforts prove futile intrigued
he inserts his hand into the hole only
to be scratched by something inside he
instantly pulls it back and a necklace
with a strange looking amulet falls out
of it later in the evening his
girlfriend Lena comes there to meet him
with some beers Chad gives her the same
necklace as a gift and puts it on her
neck as he turns around to open a beer
bottle Lena suddenly commits the
unthinkable terrified Chad runs out of
the room to get help and room 203 is
revealed as he slams the door that's the
name of the movie because killer putty
hole necklace didn't test well the scene
then cuts to a young woman named Kim
white who is about to start her college
education in a new city she has decided
to move into a newly rented apartment
with her best friend Izzy an aspiring
actress Kim's parents however are not at
all supportive of this idea because of
Izzy's past history with drugs and cases
of Overdose as they drive her towards
the city they warn her that they won't
keep any contact with her if she moves
in with Izzy despite this she ignores
them and goes to the apartment where
Izzy is waiting for her following this
the two best friends meet the creepy
looking landlord Ronin who gives them a
tour and warns them to stay out of the
bank basement he also explains that the
apartments were just renovated so all
the flats are empty and the only other
tenant on that floor is himself he then
leads them to their apartment where the
girls are mesmerized by a large stained
glass window depicting medieval knights
killing each other Kim also sees a small
hole on the wall of her room and tries
to cover it up by hanging a mirror over
it however it doesn't work as the mirror
either keeps tilting or falls to the
ground later on the two girls spend them
the night drinking and dancing on some
pretty popping beats the next morning
Izzy notices the hole in the wall and
tries reaching inside she then pulls out
the same necklace from earlier and
starts wearing it that evening the girls
visit a pub and share drinks with two
strangers after a while of hanging out
they return back to their place with
Izzy bringing one of the guys named Tony
the two make out down the hall which is
witnessed by Ronin following this Kim
goes to bed while Tony and Izzy had to
her room however she immediately falls
asleep leaving him unsatisfied Tony then
goes to the kitchen and grabs a drink
while relieving himself in the bathroom
an unseen figure passes by and moments
later he is fatally stabbed with a knife
the following morning Izzy assumes that
he left before she woke up this is
because the body has somehow vanished
from the washroom just then Kim realizes
that she's late for her orientation
class so she hurriedly gets ready and
rushes towards her college but despite
her best efforts she ends up missing it
completely as she is contemplating what
to do next a tour guide named Ian
approaches her he offers to give her a
private tour of the campus in exchange
for a coffee Kim agrees and they soon
Bond over their shared passion for
journalism through their conversation we
learn that Kim has been helping Izzy to
cope with the death of her mother and
her subsequent drug use Ian advises her
to start writing down all of her
experiences because she'll soon have to
submit a journal to a notoriously
different ult Professor afterwards Kim
returns home and finds a note from Izzy
informing her that she's out for some
drinks being alone she decides to heed
Ian's advice to write a paper on Izzy's
life late at night Kim is awakened by
fluttering sounds and Witnesses a
birdlike creature Slither into the hole
in her wall as she slowly goes to check
she is startled by banging on the door
when she opens it she finds Izzy who has
a music box in her hand and blood
spilling down from her head worried Kim
takes care of of her and keeps her
company all night in the morning she
questions Izzy about what happened and
the latter attributes her actions to
sleep walking when Kim tries to ask more
Izzy ignores the question and instead
shows her a newly installed lock on her
door to prevent any recurrence as they
Converse she reveals that she met a
woman named Sandy at the bar who happens
to be a casting assistant and she's
going to get her apart on a TV show in
turn Kim also shares about Ian
expressing that she likes him later on
Kim attends her virtual class where she
shares her intention to write her paper
based on her best friend's story she
asks whether she should take permission
from her friend before doing so sticking
to the code of Journalism the professor
tells her it's not compulsory so long as
she keeps the character anonimous in the
afternoon Izzy goes for a TV audition
while Kim goes out for a coffee date
with Ian during this she shares about
how Izzy's mother died of an accidental
overdose and this caused her to plunge
into depression at one point is I even
tried to commit the unthinkable but
failed returning home Kim continues to
work on her journal when she hears their
front door open she peeps through her
room door and sees Izzy and Sandy who
soon begin to make out Kim opts not to
disturb them and goes to bed at midnight
she wakes up to the sounds of the music
box and follows them to the living room
there she finds Izzy holding it and
staring at the stained glass window as
Kim reaches her Izzy screams as if in a
possessed R and runs towards the
restricted basement despite being scared
Kim follows her and manages to retrieve
the music box from her hand finally out
of the trance Izzy wets herself and
cries out loud due to fear being the
good friend that she is Kim brings her
back to her room and consoles her
lovingly the next day she confides in
Ian about what's been going on including
the musical box the hole in her room and
the necklace I he retrieved from it in
response he advises her to research this
matter just go to the library and look
up whole walls and also agrees to help
her with it after this the two return to
her apartment only to find Ronin staring
at the stained glass he reprimands Kim
harshly for having gone down to the
basement as the landlord leaves the two
start researching the history of the
apartment after a while they find out
about a bank manager named Liam mcnali
who had murdered his pregnant wife Karen
before killing himself in the very same
apartment they're staying Apartment 203
the PA realized that those are the names
inscribed inside the music box that Izzy
used to carry around during her
sleepwalking their conversation
eventually takes a romantic turn and
they end up sleeping together the same
night Kim is startled awake by a noise
in her room and is horrified to see a
raven at the edge of her bed she screams
in Terror waking up Ian beside her he
looks around but finds nothing so he
Comforts her saying it's just a dream
the following day while Kim is away a
delivery man brings two packets of paper
ordered by her to the apartment Izzy
receives it on behalf of her friend and
takes it to Kim's room there she finds
the pre-printed journal that Kim wrote
about her and becomes displeased
meanwhile Kim goes to meet with Milton
Briggs the janitor who had reported
Karen's murder years ago Milton is
initially hesitant to talk about it but
he agrees when Kim tells him that she
now lives in the same apartment as they
Converse he reveals that McNally's baby
survived but he doesn't know what
happened to him armed with this
information Kim returns to the apartment
only to be confronted by Izzy about the
journal she accuses her of betrayal when
she needed her the most Kim tries to
tell her about the apartment's creepy
history but Izzy dismisses her and
storms off in anger on the other hand
Ian visits St Mark's Cathedral to
compare the stained glass windows there
to the pictures he found in room 203 he
soon realizes one of his pictures is
upside down and actually depicts a demon
when he further connects the images to
Celtic Pagan symbols he learns that it
matches with an Irish mythology figure
moru who often appears in the form of a
crow and symbolizes death back at the
apartment Kim who is upset by the
argument starts hammering the hole on
the wall until a shriveled up nasty old
hand from a dead body falls out of it
freaking her out right then Ronan shows
up from behind and abducts her before
tying her up in his room it is at this
moment that he reveals he is is none
other than the son of Liam and Karen
mcnali and the necklace Izzy has been
wearing belonged to his mother according
to him the curse chooses its victim
through the necklace and compels them to
kill oneself as well as others however
Izzy is somehow resisting it likely due
to her resilience from her troubled past
fearing that moru will come after him
Ronan now intends to kill both the
tenants and present them as sacrificial
offerings meanwhile Ian who is aware of
the truth rushes to Kim's apartment to
save her upon arriving he stumbles upon
Izzy who is seemingly possessed she
pretends to seduce him but soon
showcases her demonic version and claims
his life simultaneously Ronan pins Kim
down and starts reciting a ritual from
his father's diary but as he is about to
kill her she kicks him off retrieves his
knife and stabs him in the eye she then
flees towards her room where she is
greeted by the Grim sight of Ian's dead
body heartbroken she apologizes to him
and covers with a blanket at the same
time she spots Izzy heading down to the
basement Kim follows her narrowly
escaping the grasp of ronin after a
prolonged Chase Ronin finally catches up
to her he draws his gun to shoot her but
at the same time he gets possessed by
the demon and ends up turning the gun on
himself following this Kim continues
searching for Izzy and eventually finds
her at the other end of a Long Hall
amidst the flickering lights Izzy shifts
between her real self who asks for help
and her possessed self who Grins and
laughs
scarily Kim instructs her to take off
the necklace but izy is clearly unable
to control moru within her in a sudden
turn of events Izzy attacks Kim and
stabs her in the stomach but just as she
is about to finish her off Kim rips off
the cursed necklace from her neck
finally freeing her from The Possession
the two friends then walk up to their
apartment with the intention of breaking
down the stained glass window but are
spooked by hundreds of crows flying
right outside their window in an eerie
manner despite this Kim musters up her
courage grabs the hammer and hurls it at
the window shattering it into pieces
following this Izzy rushes the injured
Kim to the hospital as she narrates her
journal in the background the movie ends
as the camera moves back into the vacant
Apartment 203 and closes in on the hole
of the shattered glass window in Pitch
Darkness a faint figure of moru makes an
appearance subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching